[Music]
good morning John it's Monday October
29th mom and dad and Catherine and
Jesslyn and Bryan and I all went up to
the top of Mount craggy or something
like that you know it's very windy but
it's also very beautiful our time has
come to an end in Nashville but it was
lovely one of the things that we did
that we didn't say we were going to do
is go to see another game of vaginas
concert and lo and behold I met Kim the
first a nerdfighter to ever recognize me
in public
Thank You Kim I feel better now because
John had been recognized before and I
hadn't it was nice to meet you but there
are two other important things that I
would like to discuss with you today
first when I was on top of Mount craggy
and I said Monday October 29th I
realized that my song day is going to
fall on Halloween and my song is not
about Halloween and I'm know if I could
make up a song about Halloween in time
to make a song for Halloween there will
most certainly be a Halloween surprise
however but it may not be myself second
mom and dad would not give up the
location of your box though they said
that you had one and after they went to
sleep I searched for it and was not able
to find it but I did find one little
stone from your childhood and I would
like to share it with all the
nerdfighters it will be of special
interest in our fighters who have
reveled in for Alaska the following is
John Green's fifth book it's called it
just isn't fair it just isn't fair by
John Green wimp I'm Alvin Loras of
course you're Alvin Loras adorable I'm
pretty smart but I'm a total nerd I wear
glasses and ugly clothes and I am
nicknamed wimp wimp once I decided to be
cool I spent $200 on Opie's $50 on jams
and 32 on a swatch you just trying to be
cool it didn't work people hated me even
more no one sat near me at lunch then I
met this kid named Rick at first you
look completely vice-versa from me he
was cool but looked pretty nice Hey
hi hi I'm Alvin I said what your name
Rick you want to play sure let's get a
ball we played until pee
he was over he gave me his phone number
six-four 75902 once I came to his house
I asked him where his father was
he said one word dead that was the most
stunning moment of my life I think I
stood there for 5 mins I thought it
would burst into tears instead he just
said my mourn days are over to this day
he is still my best friend and I still
don't know how his father died let's get
some lunch ok but we're both real
popular and everybody thinks I'm cool
including Rick you are cool
John Green was born in Indianapolis
Indiana he is 8 years old and has
written five books including this one
his latest book mean Mitch learns his
lesson will hopefully be finished by the
end of the school year note much of the
happenings in this story are true
nerdfighter from birth I hope you
enjoyed that little walk down memory
lane at John I will see you tomorrow
this is Bern Bern is manag